et alors qu'est ce que tu écris chez
curieuse mais mémoire ça rien seule
véritable question qu'on doit se poser
durant son existence et combien vous la
vie donne un mois pour 20 millions de
dollars et je serai prêt à tout rendre
jusqu'au dernier centime pour retrouver
ma vie d'avant
par hasard quelqu'un connait le nom se
trouve cholot sur normandie est-ce qu'on
garde le même long notre nouveau nom de
famille blake vous allez aucune idée de
l'endroit où tu sais ce qui vaut fonds
chez moi
elle était là pour que ça n'arrive
jamais nous en fait en sorte que je
puisse le faire
il ya une chose que je déteste c'est
d'être interrompue
le fumier et à lester ray en normandie
troublé mois
c'était quoi ça
al capone disait souvent
obtient toujours plus en étant poli
hermé
comme étant juste polis
vous êtes dans quel secteur je vais vous
montrer